[Music]
[Music]
hi Kristen thank you so much for your
time and thank you for allowing us to
chat with you during such a bizarre time
in the world how are you feeling how are
you doing I'm feeling fine I was on tour
in the middle of I've kind of been on
tour for so long that I don't know when
I wasn't on tour Vinayak's landed in New
York before I was to go to Philly I was
in I had been in Dallas Alabama and
North Carolina and then Alabama and
North Carolina I stopped the meet and
greets because the news is really kind
of just like hitting but still people
managed you know to get backstage and
stuff and so I was a little concerned
when I got here I was like oh I hope you
know because in the entertainment
business as we all know and a lot of
people are getting crap for the
celebrities or live performers getting
the test I I kind of go back and forth
cuz I know there's people that really
really need it right now
I just would have liked to know because
I have host you know what that'd be the
problem with this thing um then I was
doing in Philadelphia and that got
canceled
so I'm here in New York and I'm sort of
self quarantine II I am NOT sort of I am
is that the only way to eradicate it and
I encourage our young people and who
when you feel like the lies can't touch
you and you know you're out of school
and life is good it's actually for
everybody because they the thing about
this is it's silent it's not like 9/11
where we can see it it's silent and it's
in it's in some way scarier so if we if
we eradicate it and we all you know just
literally go out for emergencies then we
might you know will overcome it yeah
definitely have a shot of at least
stabilizing the curve and getting one
step closer to having a healthier
country as we once knew it but you're
feeling good everything new okay good
that's so good to hear absolutely I've
been cleaning like like like I never
cleaned so much in my life my mother
would be so proud of me so I want to
know so where are you right now and who
are you kind of hold up with I'm in New
York City in my apartment and my
boyfriend is here from Nashville he was
to do a gig with the artist ty Herndon
at Birdland
Jezza last week and we were kind of both
on pause because I was heading to Philly
he was going to be here and once
everything kind of hit we made a mutual
decision that he would stay here he does
it just to be honest and it made me feel
safer and better you know it that's
what's going on and I'm so grateful that
he's here so grateful yeah I mean what
are you guys doing to sort of make these
long days go by a little faster I mean
what is keeping you guys occupied okay
we have binge-watched
love is blind we have been we've been
watched a lot of things dr. pimple
popper we are he's a guitarist I don't I
know I can't say my show I just can't
good in the world to dr. Sanders I know
she's a great woman but there's two
types of people in the world people like
me who can't watch it in people like you
who clearly can't get it you know I know
one of my good friends Kathy Najimy is
like I cannot I will not watch that I
know it is a core fine we're gonna do
that actors fun here a lot of Broadway
stars are doing a month full of concerts
from our apartment and I've got one
coming up and and of course those that
know me know that I want people to laugh
so I'm going I'm doing a full-on thing I
can't tell but I'm just going to try to
make people laugh I want people to
remember that through this we must laugh
or we will lose hope and so I'm looking
for ways to laugh I joined tik-tok which
I find very entertaining we have a lot
of questions about that Mike sweet sweet
Chris
your tick tock account is very quickly
becoming a favorite amongst the et
employees oh we have been putting your
tick tocks in our group chat we have
been viciously laughing I mean tell me
everything about like who comes up with
these concepts who's filming them for
you
well Josh my boyfriend is here so and so
I have it my social media guru I call
her name's Lindsay she's my girl she's
like you're always run around singing
high notes
maybe you just clean something and sing
a high note and I was like but that's
just me on a Monday that's not exciting
and she said it is funny so I started
doing it and now well you know so yeah
well somebody last night posted their
dog on my latest tick tock I think it's
the latest one where he's trying to
match my pitch and it's the cutest thing
you've ever seen I like to watch like
the little kids and yeah yeah and that I
hope is making them laugh and it's
definitely inspiring me I'm gonna you
know get rid of these things I want to
say this too this is weird this is kind
of a weird thing
girls who have long nails I think we
should get rid of them here's why they
collect things and they it's not
sanitary right now you gotta leave them
yeah yeah so now we might as well do
without them I'm gonna soap mine off and
it'll probably take the rest of the time
we're in quarantine but I'm gonna soap
mine off and I'm gonna clip them and
short and I'm gonna practice piano and
practice guitar and yeah that's my mindo
you know I have so many kind of like
quick rapid-fire questions that I'd love
to ask you answered what you're bingeing
it's love is blind and dr. pimple popper
is there anything else any new movies or
TV shows you've gotten into assumably
all of the housewives do you have a
favorite danger see at the current
moment reality makes reality feel better
don't judge me that is well quite
absolutely being the musical guru that
you are is there like a soundtrack or
an artist that you kind of have on
repeat right now my gosh yes it's not
who everyone would think her name was
Eva Cassidy she's no longer with us I
think she passed an 81 of breast cancer
but anybody that wants to be inspired by
a true and Jake angelic voice listen to
her songbird album it's my favorite it
is there a lot of cooking going on at
home are you guys learn many recipes you
have a go-to snack maybe well josh is a
cook and evidently I have a really nice
kitchen I have a nice no idea you have a
nice stove I'm like I've never turned it
on and when I say I've never turned it
on I baked so I've used the oven and I
almost lit the place on fire because
evidently the lady helps me clean my
house sometimes puts pots and pans in
there so note to the wise check check
your oven to make sure you haven't put
any shoes or pots and pans or anything
out
yes what is Jewish cooking for you these
days
we made the best chicken and penne with
this new amazing low-sodium sauce we
found at the grocery store
he made that last night with Brussels
sprouts and then I'd be at two nights
ago he made spaghetti with salad what I
know I'm so lucky it pays to have Josh
around absolutely not Josh around now
are you someone who is still getting up
in the morning and getting dressed or
you kind of enjoying a living at home
outfit dress I got it on tour not long
ago I got a Winnie the Pooh Wednesday in
the children's department true story
this a man in my tic TOCs so I'm wearing
bad a lot if I go outside I had to go
outside three times for like to take up
a medication or whatever I come back I
throw immediately hand sanitizer I throw
them in the in the washer I deny him to
take a risk I am wearing yoga pants
maybe an easy you know thank you and my
Oklahoma City Thunder t-shirt that's
what I'm basically wearing that in my
onesie I love that you always have to be
repping for those KC love that why do I
need to stuff myself into myself
jeans right now why I don't meet we will
get back to those days but yet for now I
agree I'm being comfortable myself yes
um you know I wanted to talk about some
some really wonderful things that you're
doing of course you're gonna be a part
of the Rosie O'Donnell show which
everyone is so excited about what was it
about that that made you say absolutely
yes let's do it because in a lot of ways
Rosie is the one who discovered me all
those years ago when I first hit the
scene and I didn't know what was going
on next thing I know I'm invited on her
show to sing a song and that song was
Taylor the latte boy and that song was
it began a beautiful friendship and a
mentorship and to this day she is like
my sister so it wasn't even a well oh I
don't know it wasn't even I'm like yeah
and what do you mean people can make
donations to the actor son yes and then
I'll be a part of the concert series
that would be laying mines coming up
soon on it on a separate night and I'm I
want it there's there's more to do and
I'm sure going to be inspired and I'd
love for your listenership and and the
people who watch this to weigh in but
you know doctors are now I'm going to be
starting to consider wearing scarves and
I don't know how this works because I
have I've years of traveling I am a
scarf person because of the throat and
I've collected them and I'd love to give
scarves to doctors if they if need be I
just don't know how how that works
because of course contamination so I
don't know but something will inspire me
and I'll do it
I love that um and that's a testimony to
your giving heart you're always thinking
of ways that you can use your gifts or
your talents to give back and I can't
tell you how much that means to me as
someone who's a fan thank you well there
is something else I've been doing I
remember before I cuz I'm gonna take a
heat some heat for what I'm about to
show you
I'm a bedazzler I've been also doing the
corona dance before Corona was a thing
I've worried
I can sanitize the plane seats I wear a
mask
I wear hats farts and so dazzling is a
big part of my life and this is a
bedazzled mask and with lips on it and I
don't yeah and I know people are saying
oh no no but the thing is as I was doing
this before so we'll give you the
creativity points yes yeah Aisling is a
very specific skill set and I love it
speaks to your shiny and sparkly person
you tease what it is you're gonna be
singing when you're on the Rosie
O'Donnell show is it going to be Kitchen
surprise it's a surprise but I promise I
promise it will be uplifting and and as
far as the other show for the actors fun
that I'll do I've only got 20 minutes
but I encourage people to watch start
watching a half hour before your
surprise what's gonna I mean you know I
may be I think I'm on Broadway I don't
know well you bring up Broadway I end
you of all people know it's such a place
and it's a place where people go to
escape and it is gonna be a place that
we can't access for you know the next
few weeks what is your message to people
who seek that kind of entertainment to
make themselves feel a little better
first of all I want to say that PBS is a
cool place to watch live performances
they have Austin City Limits everything
from Austin City Limits to the myth they
have Broadway shows that they filmed I
would encourage people to watch that
Network believe it or not that's what I
would say access TV anything that has
live performance I think people are
craving it I think that's why shows like
the mask singer and American Idol and
the voice are so inspiring America's Got
Talent
because people are craving what we do
which is live performance you know I
think probably once a week I'll go on
and do something live just because
I can ever all I can ever do is go back
to the music I'm I'm not a mathematician
I'm not a great driver I'm terrible at
tech but I love music that's something I
can do so
I'm gonna I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna call some of my famous
friends and have conversations with them
live so people so they can see have you
already started reaching out yeah I'm
gonna yeah I'm gonna do that cuz I and I
want people I want our fans and I want
regular people just feel to ask normal
questions just regular old questions
staying open to the to to not just my
fans but people and don't forget fans
okay
people is the most important we need it
we need it more than I mean Barbra
Streisand's sang it people people who
need me but we need that more than
anything right now
and the thing is we can't touch so we
have to do it like this yeah you gotta
hit our feelings that's the only way
you'll to truly connect and and I don't
mean to harp on it but I think fans
would love to know who have you put out
asks to you know we know you're close
with Ariana Grande we know you've got a
lot of famous friends is there a chance
we could see you
teaming up with some of these people oh
sure these names are gonna come off yeah
that's it you give us one and some some
surprises well you know Kathy Najimy I
don't look you know her she's a great
actor sure she's shown I'd be having a
conversation but that's just one person
okay I can't wait to see what you pull
out well I mean as long as she does a
quarter constant from hocus pocus were
fine okay I'll go people would go
bananas if she doesn't you see it looks
it and speaking of people going bananas
I don't know you saw on Twitter the
other day but Seth Rogen went very viral
for live tweeting while he was watching
cats the movie and being the Broadway
you know super goddess that you are a
lot of people have expressed that they
would love to see you on Instagram live
with a bottle of wine maybe live
tweeting cats
yes I swear is there something that you
need not entertain of course yes I would
have entertained
yes I will do that well like all set
before it's all said and done we will
hit that up for sure and come you know
but let's remember like jihad is one of
my good good friends okay
blade I've never met Taylor but I love
her I'm gonna love it James Corden I
love that he's like making fun of cats
all the time on the show
I'm gonna love it but but I will be
critical I will say please girl you've
got your nails or you forgot your
wedding ring please I will I will
it's not not that's a commitment we're
shaking on that we're tight shaking my
love that so much so this weekend I know
you're part of the Hallmark family
they're bringing All Things Bright and
Mary a little earlier than expected
they're giving us a Christmas movie
marathon and part about what is your
thoughts well first of all I have to say
Hallmark you better be doing the Hall of
Fame movie this year a Christmas love
story hello snap but I will be wearing
and I will be probably talking in my
hallmark onesie watching okay and yeah
my producer Jen Aspen told me that they
were gonna do it so I'll be in either in
my Christmas sweater or my onesie watch
so live-tweeting cats live tweeting the
Hallmark Christmas movie marathon I
actually might do the life my movie if
they show my maybe I'll do that because
I saw some mistakes what do you mean oh
I saw some things like the fact that
there's a whole scene where I'm walking
like a duck outside just I look like a
penguin it's nobody thought to tell me
to put my feet in cuz I'm a textile Rena
so yeah I can live tweet that and I can
show you everything that I oh I mean I
can be grid oh I'm doing it I'm doing my
last question before we wrap up is just
you know you're someone that people turn
to for July and for happiness you're a
burst of sunshine and for anyone at home
who's feeling a little
whose uncertain about what these next
few weeks are gonna look like what is a
message of hope you can offer or if
you'd even want to sing something oh
goodness
you know it's such an interesting time
to be alive and there's a lot of people
not just a few a lot of people at home
including me wondering what's going to
happen
and if people can just literally listen
to music pick up a book pick up an
instrument if they have one in your home
and you haven't messed with in a while
if you have a thought about writing a
skin or you know maybe a Broadway
musicals being born right now that we
don't even know about you know I guess I
would always leave it with a little bit
of Broadway because Broadway is how I
made it
Broadway is where I will always feel
most at home and with my buddy Renee
Zellweger fileting as Judy sling and
winning the Academy Award I'll do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if me on
ah